hallo leute heute wieder zurück bei kg
antwortet und ich beantworte eure fragen
ja frage nur eins kommt von see um ok
wenn ich das richtig ausspreche hallo
kari ich habe ein paar fragen erstens
stimmt es wirklich dass die meisten
deutschen das englische wort welchen
service squirrel nicht aus regen können
ja das stimmt
ich kann es auch nicht können wir auf
jeden fall nicht zweitens warum muss man
für die öffentlichen toiletten bezahlen
ja in der frage über die ich mir noch
nie gedanken gemacht habt denn für mich
ist das ja normal aber man muss nicht
für alle zahlen manchmal muss man zahlen
manchmal nicht ich denke dass wir
einfach versuchen diese kosten für die
toiletten damit zu finanzieren also es
gibt ja auch öffentliche toiletten und
meint hier sind sehen aus wie offen die
toiletten sind aber privat und da zahlt
man für also in deutschland nicht
ungewöhnlich ich hab ja auch lieber also
ich habe auch lieber mehr toiletten und
zahlt dafür als dass ich allein habe
denke ich so nah und die dritte frage
ist warum haben deutsche u bahn
stationen keine screen doors fotogene
zuseher koreanische u bahn bahnsteig ja
foto ich mir angeguckt ehrlich gesagt
keine ahnung ich aber gar kein griff ich
wusste ja gar nicht dass so was in korea
gibt aber in deutschland ist das glaube
ich einfach nicht vorgeschrieben weiß
nicht vielleicht können das ja auch die
zuschauer beantworten magie oder nagy
bands schreibt hallo kari kannst du auch
einen dialekt sprechen und wenn ja
welchen
nein kann ich leider nicht weil da wo
ich herkomme ntu nein da wo ich herkam
in deutschland aus münster da hat man
zum ganz ganz leichten dialekt aber
keinen wirklichen also kein kein starken
mann verschluckt manchmal so ein paar
wörter man redet auch manchmal ein
bisschen bisschen ruhrpottler risch so
aus spaß haben wir schon mal vorgestellt
bei isar germany
aber es gibt keinen richtigen dialekt
sowie in anderen teilen von deutschland
ich würde aber gerne was lernen zum
beispiel mal berlinerisch lernen das ist
nämlich das hört sich toll an und ich
wohne jetzt in berlin da muss man
natürlich auch ein bisschen lokalkolorit
zeigen und ich denke gesandter demnächst
mal eine episode zu machen
was sagt ihr die berliner immer richtig
zum beispiel so ein tipp wenn man
berlinerisch lernt muss man nicht lernen
das ist eigentlich auch kein richtiger
dialekt sondern nur seine mundart die
hier im raum berlin gesprochen wird aber
sehr populär
dann sagt man zum beispiel nicht ich
sondern kennt ihr bestimmt von kennedy
ich bin ein berliner das war nämlich
tatsächlich nicht falsch ausgesprochen
sondern in berlin sagt man dazu oder man
sagt nicht man spricht nicht ge aus
sondern man sagt j solche wird ist alles
gut sagt mal in berlin statt das ist
alles gut
luca lazaro schreibt hallo karin
könntest du mir erklären was die
deutschen über italien denken und was
ihre vorstellung von der italienischen
cuisine ich glaube du meinst die küche
und nicht die cousine ist
finden sie dass wir gemütlich sind
vielen dank begrüßung oder grüße aus
italien
luca italien hat eigentlich glaube ich
ein ganz positives bild wenn man das so
verallgemeinert sein kann weil es gibt
ja viele deutsche viele italiener
italien ist sehr groß sicherlich ist
italien als erstes mal als urlaubsort
bekannt weil italien war gerade so eine
50er 60er jahren als in deutschland die
die pauschalreisen populär wurden war
italien das reiseziel und später erst
kam dann natürlich auch spanien und
tunesien und die türkei dazu aber
italien war immer so dass das
hauptreiseziel der deutschen und es gibt
ja auch viele italiener in deutschland
durch die gastarbeiter man hat viel
kontakt man mag das italienische essen
die italienische lebensart und natürlich
gibt es auch gleichzeitig so ein paar
bilder von chaotischer politik
berlusconi mafia das hat man natürlich
auch
ein bisschen 1 1 1 ganz bunt gemischtes
bild grundsätzlich sagen hat man ein
sehr gutes bild von italien in
deutschland oder was sagt ihr anderen
deutschen
seht ihr das anders super interessante
antwort von 765 hallo kari ich bin ja
soo kim und ich komme aus südkorea
seit april bin ich hier in berlin hallo
vielleicht kommst du mal bei uns vorbei
einzig hier angekommen bin war ich
schockiert weil deutsche sehr schnell
laufen und überqueren egal ob es rot
oder grün und auf der straße ist ist
ziemlich schmutzig das ist das gegenteil
von dem was ich in meinem heimatland
gelernt habe ich dachte deutsche seien
ordentlich sauber
ich hoffe das ist nur berlin yahia und
so kam was soll ich dazu sagen
du hast recht es ist wir haben ja letzte
woche groß erzählt die deutschen bleiben
immer stehen bei der ampel
das ist auch so in ganz deutschland nur
in berlin ist also fast nur in berlin
die großen städte sind natürlich ein
bisschen anders und tatsächlich wenn man
nach berlin kommt da freu mich auch
immer zu freunden die uns hier besuchen
und das einzige was sie in deutschland
sehen ist berlin berlin ist nicht
deutschland sowie new york nicht die usa
als berlin ist eine internationale stadt
eine großstadt wir haben fast vier
millionen einwohner wir haben in manchen
stadtteilen 50 prozent 60 prozent
ausländer aus ganz verschiedenen ländern
sie sind viele künstler aus aller welt
die hier leben viele start-up businesses
die hier gegründet werden
also es ist eine ganz gemischte statt
und wenn wir auf die straße gucken ja es
ist in berlin viel chaotischer als in
allen anderen städten in deutschland es
gibt sehr viele öffentliche
verkehrsmittel fußgänger leute gehen
über rot interessiert kein deswegen
ziehen auch viele leute nach berlin weil
hier alles so offen und frei ist und
tschuldigung des manchmal dreckig ist
ich finde es übrigens gar nicht sehr ich
finde dass ich finde dass er so
interessant als ich nach berlin gezogen
bin fand ich das spannend zu sehen dass
alle ja alle leute schmeißen alles auf
die straße finde ich manchmal gar nicht
so cool das sehen aber es ist auch
einfach so normal dass es wird ständig
sauber gemacht bei uns
vor der tür um zwei uhr nachts fahren
dann noch die leute lang sonntags abends
damit montags morgens die straßen wieder
sauber sind
also das ist auch berlin das gibt es in
anderen städten nicht
nathalie baye schreibt was denken wie
denken die deutschen über großbritannien
ich war ziemlich verwirrt dass die
königin da so beliebt ist ich habe ein
paar königliche sendung im zdf bemerkt
ist das richtig ja natalie das ist ein
interessantes phänomen dass es im zdf
viele royale fernsehsendung gibt also
fernsehsendung wo menschen über wie
nennt man das dann ja die königshäuser
europas berichten in deutschland gibt es
ja bekanntermaßen keinen könig und auch
keine prinzen unserer und es gibt aber
natürlich in deutschland auch viele
leute ich sag mal vorsichtig die leute
die das zdf gucken sind eher so elter
vielleicht zu über 60 und die hören sich
gerne geschichten an ob das jetzt von
königen ist oder von anderen stars ist
eigentlich egal
und wenn da eine königin kommt oder eine
hochzeit irgendwo stattfindet in
schweden norwegen interessiert uns gar
nicht sonst was da sonst passiert aber
wenn dann eine hochzeit ist von königin
prinzessin ein baby kommt plötzlich
steht das überall in den zeitungen
das gucken aber nicht alle das gucken
halt nur die leute die es interessiert
vielleicht ist das auch so ein bisschen
eine sehnsucht dass es in deutschland
keine königlichen promis gibt kann sein
weiß man nicht ja ankum mohammed
schreibt kannst du uns erklären was die
deutschen denken wenn sie über asien
denken oder südostasien ich bin aus
indonesien bei grey danke dir vielmals
jahrgang was wenn man den namen so
ausspricht auf ich was für eine frage
in asien diese riesige kontinent mit
milliarden von leuten und jetzt soll ich
dir sagen was alle deutschen über alle
asiaten denken das wird natürlich
schwierig ja aber wenn du schon so eine
pauschalisierte an sondern haben willst
dann können wir mal ganz kurz
zusammenfassen
was die deutschen über asien denken ist
vor allem geiles essen geile strände und
business viel business viel ist los auf
den straßen viele viel gewusel jeder hat
irgendwie sein eigenes business und sie
hatten sind sehr fleißig sagt man auch
die studieren sehr viel aber das ist ja
so ein allgemeines vorurteil in asien
ist auch sehr populär wenn es ans reisen
geht
viele leute aus deutschland fahren gerne
nach asien ob das jetzt thailand ist
oder wir nehmen aber auch indonesien und
da fängt schon an das ist nämlich ganz
interessant was haben wir eigentlich für
ein bild indonesien zum beispiel ist ein
riesiges land das viertgrößte land der
erde
und ich glaube so ein wirklich
differenziertes bild hat man in
deutschland nicht
indonesien war ja auch übrigens gerade
gastland bei der frankfurter buchmesse
in deutschland vielleicht hat das so ein
bisschen dazu beigetragen dass man immer
ein bisschen mehr über indonesien hat
mal ein beispiel viele deutsche kennen
bali und fahren nach bali in den urlaub
und für sie ist natürlich bali so ein
bild was man in deutschland von asien
auch von indonesien hat dabei ist es ja
auch gar nicht unbedingt typisch für in
der nähe im wallis sind kleine hinter
der hinduistische insel und indonesien
es gleichzeitig das größte muslimische
land der welt was die meisten leute gar
nicht wissen also es gibt viele sachen
die die gibt es noch zu entdecken und da
haben die leute glaube ich gar nicht so
viel wissen darüber was für ein name
schreibt hallo kari kannst du uns deinen
mann vorstellen
ja kann ich doch mal machen oder ja mein
mann oder es gibt es meinem mann zu
sagen mein mann sitzt da hinter der
kamera ich stelle euch jetzt noch vorher
mit mit der carrer käme ja und schon
läuft die kann man also das ist mein
mann liebe zuschauer wie kann ich ihn
vorstellen wie kann ich ihn beschreiben
er heißt janus er kommt aus polen ist 1
75 groß
er liebt gitarren
mark ist film zu schneiden aber vor
allem die gitarren und bananenkisten wie
in diesem bild zu sehen ist und was ganz
wichtiges erliegt gitarren so sehr dass
er immer gitarre spielt sogar wenn er
hinter der kamera steht
ja das war mein mann adriano los
schreibt wahrung ist das internet in
deutschland so beschränkt ja adrian dir
fällt auf was allen ausländern in
deutschland aufhält nur den deutschen
nicht das internet in deutschland ist
beschränkt tatsächlich ist es so dass
das internet deutschland gar nicht so
gut ist wenn man das mit anderen ländern
vergleicht gerade wenn es um mobiles
internet geht um die kosten für mobiles
internet um die netzabdeckung da hat
gerade noch ein bekannter deutscher
blogger und autor darüber geschrieben
dass das in deutschland also deutschland
ist richtig so ein digitales
entwicklungsland kann man sagen und es
hängt einfach den ganzen entwicklung
weltweit noch weit hinterher er hat da
auch so thesen aufgestellt zum beispiel
dass in deutschland wurde in den in den
2000er jahren hat die regierung quasi
umts frequenzen versteigert die konzerne
mussten dafür zahlen dass war so teuer
dass sie wiederum viel geld nicht in
entwicklung stecken konnten dass es so
seine these aber ich würde sagen ich
stell dir mal den artikel unten in die
infobox dann kannst du selber ein
bisschen mehr dazu lesen und versuchen
herauszufinden warum das internet in
deutschland so beschränkt ist witzig ist
tatsächlich dass es den deutschen gar
nicht so sehr auffällt in deutschland
ist das nicht so eine große debatte
hängt natürlich auch mit vielen sachen
zu tun politik infrastruktur allen
ausländern hingegen fällt das auf denn
in allen anderen ländern ist das
internet viel schneller und zugänglicher
das stets manchen artikeln in finnland
kostet das megabyte mobile daten 5000
prozent weniger als in deutschland könnt
ihr euch das vorstellen
in deutschland ist es also 5000 prozent
ja nicht fünfmal so viel sondern 5000
prozent teurer als überall anders als in
finnland
ja liebe leute das war's schon für diese
woche hat mich gefreut dass ihr nach
unserem spektakulären aufruf letzte mal
noch mehr fragen geschickt habt es tut
mir leid dass ich nicht immer alle
beantworten kann aber es macht mir sehr
viel spaß eure fragen zu bekommen
deswegen schickt mir einfach noch mehr
fragen und am ende möchte mich noch mal
danke sagen ganz speziell diese woche an
jamie cox jamie du bist einer von den
leuten die uns auch patrick supporten
und wir können das leider gar nicht oft
genug sagen denn wir profitieren sehr
sehr sehr von eurer hilfe und ihr habt
gesehen dass wir seit diesem monat jeden
tag ein video machen das ist für uns
sehr viel zeit sehr viel arbeit und in
dieser zeit können wir eben nichts
anderes machen dass es auch unser traum
unser traum ist es dass wir irgendwann
durch dieses projekt genug geld
verdienen dass wir dieses studio unser
equipment und auch unsere zeit damit
bezahlen können keine anderen jobs
machen müssen und nur für euch da sind
und wenn ihr mitmachen möchte diesen
traum zu ermöglichen damit ihr auch in
zukunft jeden tag ein video bekommt dann
werdet gerne teil von unserer community
über batterien
dort könnt ihr 50 cent oder 1 dollar
oder 5 dollar egal
das was ihr dazu geben möchte in unser
projekt spenden und davon zahlen wir zum
beispiel die miete von diesem studio
oder neue lichter oder die reisen wenn
man einen anderen ort fahren dafür noch
mal danke für alle die schon dabei sind
wenn ihr mitmachen möchte findet ihr den
link hier unten
danke fürs zuschauen und bis zur
nächsten woche wieder
leute ich mach das nicht zum scherz wir
brauchen mehr fragen und mehr kommentare
damit wir mehr beantworten können
schickt uns eure kommentare